ein guter ort für schweine ein leben an
der frischen luft in einer rotte mit
boden zu wühlen einer schule und einer
hütte voller stroh kleine idylle und
weit weg von der realität für
konventionelle mester eine
unrealistische wunschvorstellung wenn
ich mir überlege ich könnte ein stall
bauen wie ich ihn bauen wollte und ich
müsste nicht daran denken werden wir das
am ende ab kaufte sich zeitlich und so
würde ich meine ein paar gerne draußen
halten ich würde die super gerne ins und
ich würde mir nicht den ganzen tag
gedanken darüber machen welche
genehmigungsbehörde welche
kontrollbehörde kommt morgen und
schreibt mir vor wie ich irgendwas zu
machen habt sondern einfach auch
vertrauen darauf sagen dass ich ihn so
gut ausgebildet sind dass ich weiß was
meine tiere brauchen und dass ich ja das
vernünftig machen
florian hollmann mästet 4000 schweine
franz keller hat etwa 50 es sind zwei
welten in der infobox könnt ihr bei
florian hollmann in den konventionellen
stahl schauen
in diesem video geht es um alternativen
um die utopie auf dem falkenhof
[Musik]
wir sehen jetzt heute hier bei franz
keller auf einem hof der war sternekoch
und ist immer noch gross hat sich aber
sozusagen aus notwehr dafür entschieden
selbst landwirt zu werden und da wollen
wir uns heute einfach mal anhören und
anschauen wie landwirtschaft auch
funktionieren kann
ich habe extra meine wander und reck
show angezogen damit wir die schweine
mal besuchen können ja aber es ist ja
schön warm und trocken viel zu trocken
deshalb müssen wir nicht durch den macho
komisch diese brauchen erhalten ich kann
es einfach wenn zum lebewesen geht nicht
immer nur alles optimal wirtschaftlich
machen und das gleich muss halt teurer
werden das ist ein seiner grundsätze und
die haltung auf dem falkenhof seine
umsetzung das geht halt alles hier mit
einem anderen ablaufen im anderen tempo
weil es bei holt es nicht alles
optimiert ich hab gelesen
sie sind aus wut zum bauer geworden so
richtig es hat mal einer geschrieben
oder blut war es am anfang nicht sondern
es war einfach der wunsch nach
anständigen produkten ohne tierwohl gibt
es keinen guten geschmack glaubt er
deshalb hält franz keller seit einigen
jahren seine eigenen hühner kühe und
schweine auf dem falkenhof als koch
stehen für ihn bewusstes essen und
genuss im vordergrund
zur begrüßung gibt es daher wein auf den
regeln der hoffentlich bald kommt darauf
stoßen waren du gut mal wo der hendrick
bleibt mit dem gras ja franz keller tut
auch nicht so als würde er selbst
ausmisten oder füttern
dafür hat der geschultes personal aus
osteuropa er zieht die fäden
kontrolliert und hat ein auge auf seine
tiere einigen schulen intensivieren und
auch von der förster dabei dann dauert
es eine halbe stunde dann stehen sie
schlange
bis auf zwei mal dazu ja in der
konventionellen haltung lebt ein tier
von der befruchtung bis zum tod weniger
als ein jahr
startpunkt ist die künstliche
befruchtung dann kommen die mutter soll
ihn warte stände von dort in abwehr
gebuchten danach sind die kleine der
ferkelaufzucht danach noch drei monate
mastbetrieb schlusspunkt ist der
schlachthof alles ist optimiert die
produktion sicherer
das macht die tiere billiger der preis
des fleisches so nieder dass der bauer
darauf achten muss dass er so wenig
verlust wie möglich hat und das
mutterschweine in den ersten zehn
stunden wenn die geboren hat ist die
natürlich fix und fertig und ist ein
riesen tier das seht ihr ja wenn die
sich dann einmal dreht und die kleinen
können noch nicht kriegen dann sind sie
halt blatt wir haben fast in jedem dorf
haben wir so ein schweinchen was told
gedrückt wird alle die es schaffen
wachsen zuerst mit der mutter sauer und
dann mit den anderen schweine in der
gruppe auf dem falkenhof werden die
bunten bentheimer gehalten eine alte
robuste rasse und was ist jetzt so ein
schwein wenn man das jetzt verkaufen
würde so ein schwein was jetzt quasi
schlachtreif ist was ist es dann jetzt
wert wenn es so lebt ich könnte mir das
gar nicht leisten die so aufzuziehen
gucken was ein kilo schweinefleisch
kostet von einem schwein was fünfeinhalb
monate auf dem hof ist und meine sind
bis zu 15 16 monate auf dem hof das
heißt sie müssen viel länger gefüttert
werden es macht mehr arbeit mehr
aufmerksamkeit ja mit der sohle jetzt
mehr dass das sind alles dinge die
arbeitsintensiv sind das meiste fleisch
geht an das restaurant seines sohnes nur
kleine mengen gibt es im direktverkauf
auf der homepage ist alles ausverkauft
ich habe ja wie gesagt auch wenn dem
schweinemäster gesprochen der hat jetzt
ein jahr lang sein betrieb vom vater
übernommen hat dann hof voller tiere und
sagt na klar wenn der verbraucher hat es
zahlen würde dann schicke ich dir auch
nach draußen
der hof ist jetzt aber aktuell so
strukturiert und ihm fehlt die
sicherheit sagen wir mal zu investieren
in xy weil er gar nicht weiß wo sich was
hin entwickelt dann soll er klein
anfangen und dann soll er meinetwegen 90
prozent von seinem ist weiter
produzieren war soll jetzt produziert
und soll im kleinen daneben anfangen
sollen hofverkauf damit machen und sagen
hier guck mal
die wurst von denen könnte daher bei
maria metzger kaufen das wasser hier auf
meinem hof macht einfach anfangen es
klingt so einfach ich frag mich trotzdem
die ganze zeit wie realistisch ist seine
utopie in der haltung und im konsum wäre
das wirklich massentauglich aber
trotzdem geht er jetzt auch hier quasi
es geht finanziell gerade so oder wie
ist es jetzt mit den schweinen also
jetzt bei mehr finanziell eigentlich nur
weil ich auch gäste hier habe weil ich
für gäste kochen denen das zeige ich mag
lesungen auf dem hof wir machen
kochkurse und so und die sind wenn man
wäre relativ teuer und davon lebe ich
eigentlich dafür hole ich mir dann das
geld eben so machen zu können
weil wenn ich jetzt nur vom produkt
leben müsste von der wurst die wir
machen von dem gleich dann werde ich
wahrscheinlich noch weniger kundschaft
die bereit ist das zu bezahlen
aber dann ist es ja quasi trotzdem was
was man jetzt dann nicht im großen stil
zur ernährung
man muss es vormachen ich mache es
einfach vor weil ich jetzt will und weil
ich jetzt für gut finde und versuchen so
viel wie möglich leute zu begeistern
sagen leute ihr seid doch bescheuert er
kaufte für euer tolles auto ein motoröl
für 38 euro und für euch kauft das
billigste kassel irgendwoher man wisse
nicht wo es herkommt westlings was
gemacht wurde
für 8 euro 50 für euren körper dinger
heißen lebensmitteln es ist eine große
portion idealismus wenn es ums essen
geht versteht ja keinen spaß
genauso wenig beim tierwohl deshalb ist
für ihn klar dass fleisch teurer werden
muss mit allen konsequenzen
aber trotzdem es jetzt immer wieder doch
auch das argument gerade wenn es um
fleisch geht dass gesagt wird dann
können es sich der der arme teil der
gesellschaft kann sich das dann nicht
mehr leisten und das ist auch wieder so
an ganz ganz böses wort dann heißt es
ist unsozial tschuldigung die leute
essen nur so viel fleisch weil es billig
ist wenn es nicht so billig wäre würden
sie mehr oder weniger es nun werden sind
deshalb krank werden
fleisch soll er luxusgut statt
massenware sein
zweimal die woche welches zu essen
findet er okay er selbst ist mehr für
fleischlose ernährung hat er wenig
verständnis
nur vegan oder vegetarisch zu ernähren
ist keine alternative
warum es keine alternative weil es keine
normale ernährung ist man kann mit wenig
fleisch oder kaum fleisch leben das ist
vegetarisch aber muss ich mir das antun
würdest du dir das antun wenn du so ist
es mit tollen richtig gutes fleisch
schmeckt oder wie tollen der richtige
leberwurst schmecken
die meisten den wir heute haben die
vegetarier sind alles protest vegetarier
wir sind alles vegetarier weil sie das
zeug nicht kaufen wollen chapeau es
schon mal nicht schlecht
seine thesen sind steil und nicht
unumstritten trotzdem bleibt war seine
schweine leben artgerecht und er hat
große freude daran
der falkenhof hat keine bio lizenz und
bekommt keine subventionen franz keller
sind die anträge zu anstrengend seine
forderung regionale strukturen
aufklärung der verbraucher in
ernährungslehre in der schule mehr
tierwohl und eine andere
subventionspolitik mit kritik hält er
sich nicht zurück
wir brauchen andere landwirtschaft wie
kommen wir denn da hin
das muss über die politik kommen wir
müssen unseren landwirtschaftsministerin
solang tschuldigung im hintern treten
bis sie das auch macht aber sie ist
natürlich in diesen job reingekommen
über irgendwelche lobby kästen die dann
sagen leute was wir machen ist gut dass
muss weiter gemacht werden
wir wollen exportweltmeister von
schweinefleisch werden nur weil die
jetzt in china nicht mehr nachkommen die
haben kohle ohne ende jetzt wollen sie
auch alle fleisch wir machen wir machen
die landschaft wir machen die das
grundwasser wir machen alles kaputt nur
damit wir billig schweinefleisch
produzieren können geht's noch aktuell
gehen 2,4 millionen tonnen
schweinefleisch jedes jahr ins ausland
das ist grob die hälfte der produktion
deutschland gehört zu den größten
exporteuren der welt neue schärfere
gesetze würden haltung und produktion
verändern und fleisch würde teurer
werden und damit nicht mehr so
lohnenswert für den export aber jetzt
lebt als dann der auch ein stück weit
vom export wenn wir unser geld machen
müssen mit export von schweinefleisch
dann ist eh schon zu spät
das ist nur interessant weil es
gefördert wird weil subventioniert wird
und weil der tierschutz keine rolle
spielt der tierschutz zum beispiel mit
karten von den schwänzen und kastrieren
ohne betäubung das ist vom eigentlich
schon längst verboten und wird jedes
jahr wieder eine neue sondergenehmigung
das ist verarschung sonst gar nichts die
sollen sich darauf einstellen und dann
kostet es halt mehr und fertig die
deutsche tierhaltung ist für den
weltmarkt optimiert und solange das so
ist sind radikale veränderungen
unwahrscheinlich sagen viele expertinnen
aktuell bezieht der preis wie der
tiergesundheit faire
produktionsbedingungen noch
umweltschäden mit 1 wenn es nach
umfragen geht wären viele verbraucher
innen bereit für bessere standards mehr
zu bezahlen
die realität an der kasse sieht
allerdings anders aus
man spricht von der bürger konsumenten
lücke denn bei der kaufentscheidung gilt
offenbar schlägt das gute gewissen wir
können auch unsere bauern fördern und
unsere landwirtschaft in denen wir den
die möglichkeit geben qualität
herzustellen
und nicht massenware wenn es um tiere
geht es massen waren ganz ganz
schwieriges problem
deswegen macht er es anders sein tieren
geht es so gut dagegen dass die
allermeisten schweine in konventionellen
mastställen auf guitar bühnen stehen
kämpfte er an
mit seinen ideen und seinen mitteln auch
der konventionelle meister florian
wünscht sich veränderungen will aber
weiter schweine halten
ich meine ich auch meine freie
entscheidung dass ich das mache und ich
kann ja auch morgen sagen ich lasse es
sein und würde mich halt freuen wenn es
politische rahmenbedingungen gibt die es
mir ermöglichen dass ich halt auch die
tiere anders halten kann nur im moment
sieht es ja noch leider noch nicht aus
trotzdem ist es jetzt in der aktuellen
diskussion wichtig dass wieder darüber
gesprochen wird und dass wir uns einfach
vor augen führen wo das allermeiste
fleisch herkommt nämlich eben nicht so
wie hier von sauen die mit ihren kleinen
in einem gehege leben wo der nebendran
der esa ist und wo die tiere alt werden
können und dann geschlachtet werden und
das komplette schwein verarbeitet wird
und dass wir da wieder hinkommen dafür
muss ich echt einiges wandeln
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie es ist 4000
schweine zu mästen kommt ihr hier zur
ersten folge ganz viele andere wichtige
themen findet ihr auch in unserer
playlist